if you want a sexy bus we are gonna sell
sexy buses that is great Los Angeles
known for its sunshine palm trees
swimming pools Hollywood movies and oh
yeah traffic's so bad you could spend
hours in your car trying to get wherever
you're going what are we doing today we
are driving on some on Los Angeles
freeways that's me and producer Alex
Manning hanging out with Baruch
Feigenbaum a transportation policy
analyst at Reason Foundation and we're
going to find some that are congested
we're not gonna have to try very hard
because they're all congested in fact a
recent study from the American highway
users Alliance found that Los Angeles
has 12 of the 50 worst bottlenecks in
the United States we're really in
bumper-to-bumper traffic here this is
this is great this is I mean it's not
great that the traffic is so bad but
it's a great example of just how much of
a mess this really is of course cities
throughout the country have this problem
it's certainly not limited to that to LA
but LA is the worst in many metrics
according to the city's mobility 2035
plan which is really just a plan for
what the city wants to be in the
upcoming decades the solution to this
congestion is through in part increased
density to promote more rail based
transit and put some more wide bike
lanes and sidewalks in so people will
get out of their cars and short the plan
seems to foresee a future where la looks
more like New York City where people
commute day to day without cars and live
in densely populated downtown areas
everybody wants to be New York City but
what people forget is New York City was
built up a long time ago and it was
built when cars were not popular and in
some cases didn't even exist we go back
to the 1800s and so it was built around
walking and being able to take transit
Los Angeles was built around the
automobile because we had it through the
years as different parts of Los Angeles
developed the car made it easier to get
to those places until eventually people
had many places to go all over the city
in a given day LA unlike say New York is
a system where people live in met many
areas and work in many areas there's a
downtown but a very small share of jobs
perhaps 5% are actually in the down
or and so you've got people going from
everywhere to everywhere and that's why
Feigenbaum says the car in los angeles
is more than a means of transportation
the car is a symbol it's a symbol of
personal mobility it's a symbol of
freedom it's a symbol of basically
living in Southern California and when
folks say things like well we need to
get people out of their cars it's more
than just a commuting it's sort of a
whole way of life it's with that in mind
that Reason Foundation came up with its
own solutions for all of Southern
California
and while the cost is seven hundred
billion dollars about half of that comes
out of existing tax revenues and the
other half comes out of tolls
specifically toll lanes like these
already seen in a neighboring County the
toll Ferenc is based on the congestion
in the lane and it actually provides
folks with in alternative to sitting in
this congested traffic high income low
income we find that folks who or what we
would say working-class
paycheck-to-paycheck value these Express
lanes the most because they often have
to get someplace they have to get to
pick up their children from daycare
daycares charge extra by the minute they
have a job that they actually have to be
on time for that's it I think is an
interesting criticism of these toll
roads is that it's going to put together
some sort of class system on our
freeways rich people get to ride in the
toll lanes and the us poor people get
the right in the regular lanes right
what's the what's your answer to that
well my answer is if you look at the
folks who actually use the lanes in the
places where they are actually in use
right now including some lanes in Los
Angeles that's not what you see the five
most common car makes in the lanes are
Toyota Honda Ford Chevrolet and I
believe Nissan and the types of cars are
Toyota Corollas Ford f-150s mean these
are certainly not luxury vehicles or the
people's cars these are the people of
cars that's right it's a solution for
the people another solution for the
people get those slow free trucks off
the highway and get all those drivers
taking shortcuts off the surface streets
with european-style tunnels so we have
six proposed tunnels most people already
have sewer in septic tunnels under there
under their houses they just don't know
about they just don't know about them
and I don't know about you
having you know sewer running under my
tunnel doesn't under my house sounds a
lot worse than a car yeah that's that's
just me but it can open oh it's yummy I
hope it doesn't leak some other
suggestions recent foundation has come
up with include under passes or
overpasses for the worst clogged surface
streets and buses lots and lots of buses
we have bus rapid-transit we have
Express bus Express bus would use these
Express managed lanes we're building on
the expressways sort of to give buses an
option to have a reliable commute time
why not son get people on rail instead
but Los Angeles has been building a rail
system for 25 years and you can argue
already I would argue that the all of
the places where rail possibly makes
sense are already served by rail but a
rail system is so metropolitan so hip so
sexy it's nothing like riding the dumpy
city bus or is it we've got BRT now bus
rapid transit which is what we're
proposing on surface street it looks
really great I can get ask you a sexy
bus if you want a sexy bus we are gonna
sell sexy buses that is great it is
still a sexy bus it's a little bit more
than your traditional bus but it's still
way way cheaper sometimes an order of 10
usually between 3 and 10 times cheaper
than a rail line and here's the thing
about LA it's a very large land area in
popular places to live work and go out
to eat are always changing cars and
buses are able to adapt to that rapidly
changing culture as long as you can find
parking when you get there